foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work
we really love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money the call is free and some
say the advice is worth exactly what you
pay for it the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
thanks for being with us Chris is with
us in Dallas Texas to start this hour hi
Chris welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave thank you so much for having me
sure what's up
so I'm a high school senior right now
taking just kind of a personal finance
class and I was just wondering if you're
concerned about how you know the
national debt reaching 30 trillion
dollars and how that should affect just
our overall personal finance strategy
[Music]
um
well I'm sorry as a high school senior
you're having to worry about such things
um
uh
I've got a long history of fretting and
alternately being angry about the uh
national debt being out of control
mainly because it represents a congress
that's out of control and we don't seem
to have the backbone in the American
people to vote the bozos out
so they keep spending
like there's no tomorrow
and um everybody's a little bit lazy
about it so it just keeps going and
going and going so yeah I'm with you it
it's bothersome it's um obviously
there's a Tipping Point somewhere I will
tell you that the end of the world has
been predicted as long as I can remember
due to the national debt or due to
whatever other Boogeyman you want to
come up with and I actually read a book
uh when I was a little bit older than
you called bankruptcy 1984. that
predicted that the national debt was
going to hockey stick and the nation
would collapse in 1984. obviously that
was wrong
there was another book that a friend of
mine wrote called the coming economic
earthquake predicting the exact same
thing in the same decade
he was wrong
I had another friend of mine wrote a
book about the end of the world due to
why 2K do you know what that is Chris
yes yeah
exactly when the computers all turned
over the world was going to come down
and the uh the uh uh we were a little
bit worried that the entire electric
electronic grid would collapse and a lot
of people bought water and bullets and
uh all kinds of things to get ready for
the end times and the uh New Year's Eve
came and went nothing happened except
three days later the stock market went
through the roof
and so um I just I I have honestly I'm
not making fun completely but I look
back on all the things I've worried
about and none of them have happened so
um I think it's bad because I think it
represents a lack of discipline on the
American people's part and on our
quote-unquote Representatives part I
think it's pitiful
it's outrageous but does it affect my
investing not a dime
not a dime I don't sit and worry about
it I invest based on good long-term
track records because the debt's been
out of control as long as I've been
alive
and uh so I've been investing and
investing and investing if it ever
absolutely fell in on itself there's not
anything you could have invested in
except bullets that would protect you
so I wouldn't I wouldn't fret about it
um and the next time someone can you
know comes to me and one of the other
things I'll just as a side note for our
listeners out there and for Jay Jay may
not know this about me um it is one of
the things I have vowed that when I get
old I am not going to be one of those
financial guys that writes an end times
book
because most people in my world you know
we go along we teach people to get
wealthy we teach them about all this and
then we get enough knowledge that this
stuff starts concerning us and so we
write the end of the world book and it's
coming soon usually when we get old and
I've just vowed I'm not even if I'm
tempted I'm not going to write as a
matter of fact I've even told my
publishing team to refuse to publish it
if I did write it so if you have a
moment I'm making the mistake of doing
it to myself burn burn the manuscript
and throw it in the fire just it it
apparently
um
takes more than a single president being
a because we've had multiple of
that
it takes more than
I think it takes to collapse This Thing
Called America yeah you know I I
remember thinking that when X or Y
president got elected way back there
like before some of you were born that
that was it that's a sign it's over yeah
Jesus is coming you know and he didn't
and we didn't die and the nation
survived the idiocy in the white house
that's true and the lack of Morality In
the White House and the whatever in the
White House said and you know we'll
survive um
whatever we're going through right now
it's just we're more resilient than I
than I think we think we are in the
middle of the night when we wake up
scared that's a really good point Dave I
do think that we're resilient as people
and also as a nation and a lot of this
stuff is so cyclical you know the sky is
falling and then somebody comes and does
you know one or two things that are just
you know whatever and everybody does a
big deep breath and then somebody else
comes and they spend more and it's like
uh you know I think all this stuff just
goes in a big wheel and uh you know for
your own piece sometimes you just gotta
let it let it remain external and not
let it get into you so much yeah and
when you look back on it you go you know
it I it was it was a lot bigger deal in
my head yeah I mean you talked to
somebody who lived during the Great
Depression yeah that that was real yeah
I find in moments like this when you
just look back and go okay it gives you
a little bit of perspective to go okay
this is this is not any crazier than any
other moment in history you know what I
mean yeah and and
yeah I think the um you know what is
different
is access to
conspiracy theories facts it's the
social media internet I mean because it
used to be you had to really work to
find Kooks that's right and now they are
delivered to you because you've been
looking at other Kooks and so the
algorithm sends you a holistic oh it'll
just put it up you don't got stuck in
the kooky algorithm and you're gonna get
lit up with Kooks and so you know if you
think the world's coming to an end and
you type that in about three times
you're gonna have a lot of incoming End
Time stuff showing up on your desktop
and all of a sudden you're gonna start
to believe the dead gum world's coming
to an end and it's the same thing as you
know again when I started all of this a
million years ago we didn't have the
inputs you know the moral of the story
is there is a moral to the story we're
going to finally get there watch your
inputs
so good Dave you know you become what
you consume and who you hang around with
so are you watching the news 24 7. right
you're gonna be pissed off all the time
because it used to just be that it was
Fox News MSNBC and you go you know I
used to be Walter Cronkite and you had
to wait till six o'clock well then
there's that that was it and then you
got 24 7. 24 7. and then you got 24 7
both sides of the political Spectrum yep
uh yelling at each other yep and now you
got YouTube Instagram and all and it's
not even it's not even real news outlets
anymore it's just it's just
the stuff that we call news now we used
to call tabloid oh true that well I can
go on there and make news and somebody
listen to me well there you go
I might have to only I'll tell you the
truth I won't be out here telling you
fake news I'll tell you the truth
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsey Way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phone's a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
there's been consistent focus on and
funding for traditional subjects in the
world of Education like math and science
but there's been a consistent lack of
focus on Common Sense stuff like
personal finance education in the
classroom kids have to memorize the
periodic table but they can't balance a
checkbook who they don't know how to
stay out of debt the financial literacy
crisis in America 2023 report focuses on
the lack of personal finance education
in America however we come to the rescue
with Ramsey Solutions foundations and
personal finance taught now in 48 of the
high schools but here's what the key
findings of this report said 88 percent
of U.S adults said high school did not
leave them fully prepared three and four
U.S adults so the Years After High
School they often or sometimes felt
stressed because of money lack of
knowledge well that's just everybody
yeah that is everybody
you didn't need to spend a bunch of
money on that research all you got to do
is talk about four people and you can
figure out that we're not taught this
stuff in school anymore from the first
time I wrote the little blue version of
financial peace and I carried around the
trunk of my car one of the first times I
ever set it out on a table after I spoke
and I went back to work the book table
and sell my little book for 12 dollars
from then on people would come back
there and go you know they should teach
this stuff in schools uh-huh it's come
up from day one of me starting this
stuff 30 years ago and so we are
and guess what this month is financial
literacy month woohoo hey hey
love it and to do that uh to celebrate
that we're going to honor a bunch of
teachers and uh so what we're going to
be doing in this process is we have the
Ramsey teacher appreciation giveaway
sponsored by the Army National Guard we
think teachers are heroes
as a matter of fact we're downright sure
of it so one teacher no purchase
necessary will win a 5 000 vacation wow
that's nice yeah because you need a
vacation I'm telling you and two more
teachers are going to win a three
thousand dollar vacation of their
choosing you go wherever you want to go
we're going to fund it along with help
from our friends at the Army National
Guard so uh way to go teachers so the
giveaway ends April 30th no purchase is
necessary but you've got to be a teacher
to register or if you're register and
you're not teacher you're not going to
get it so there you go get your name in
the running go to ramseysolutions.com
teacher tell teachers you know
to come and register to
ramseysolutions.com teacher because we
are definitely giving somebody a sweet
vacation that's what we want to do there
that's nice and they get to choose where
they want to go to it's not like all
expenses paid to
some some place in the Caribbean I got a
discount on yeah that's not no it didn't
happen just five thousand dollar lies
real dollars and we're going to give you
that exact amount and you're going to go
towards your a place of your choosing
Dale is with us in uh Jacksonville
Florida hi Dale how are you
doing good hey I had a question about
using land as a down payment and what
you're on that
is
down payment for what
a house so when I talked to Churchill
Mortgage they said that we could use the
land our five acres it's free and clear
um as a collab like as our down payment
oh okay absolutely and actually you
don't have a choice
you have to you have to because here's
how it works all right you're going to
take out a construction loan and they're
going to take a lien against the
property that the house is being built
on which happens to be this land
so now the land is wrapped into the deal
immediately and when the construction is
finished and the construction loan has
fully funded the building of the
property you will you will then put in
place what's called a takeout loan a
you're going to take out the
construction loan with the permanent
mortgage that pays off the construction
loan uh and is in the amount of the
construction loan and guess what the
equity the total house will be worth X
which includes the land
and you end up with just the mortgage at
the end of the story and so it has
worked its way into becoming the down
payment because it's in your Equity at
that point you see what I'm saying
yeah so it's already more equitable
is that what you're saying no I'm saying
that okay the five thousand eight or the
five acres is worth what
um about 70 000. okay and what are you
gonna spend on the build
um probably about 200. okay and that 200
is probably going to be worth 250 actual
appraisal when you complete it because
you're building it right okay and so
you're going to have 270 in the property
or I'm sorry no you're going to have a
mortgage of 200 but you're going to have
a value of
um 250 of about 320. the equity is the
difference so you'll actually only have
200 200 000 in the whole package when
you're done
but because the 70 acres is paid for and
because you're building it for less than
appraisal I'm sure sure you're not
paying full appraisal to build a
property uh you're going to end up with
about a 320 000 property that you only
owe 200 on the difference is 70 000
that's called your equity
okay and so it makes sense and so you
see what happened is the land ended up
being like a seventy thousand the land
and the better deal on the house ended
up being like a seventy thousand dollar
down payment
okay and so like we have some money set
aside already like four down payment
should we I mean no it's okay go ahead
and put that down too good just that
means you're just gonna borrow even less
and have a larger Equity but you're
gonna have less debt because we want to
get this house paid off as soon as
possible
okay how much have you got to set aside
not much we just finished paying off
that so
I'm thousand right now but I was just
curious what your thoughts were on that
is it above your emergency fund
um no we have a different emergency fund
we have 15 in emergency funds okay
achieve your emergency fund plus ten
thousand so yeah put the ten thousand or
any other money you can scrape together
while you're building and that makes you
end up with less than a 200 000 mortgage
thus more Equity Equity Dale is value of
the property the whole property minus
what you owe that's your Equity that's
what you call that at what point Dave
let me let me take this question one
point further because so we're talking
about a 200 000 loan 70k for the land is
there a ratio land to home value that
you would say hey that land is not gonna
I want you to put cash with that yeah do
you see what I'm saying yeah you're
unless you're on a huge tract of land uh
and five acres is not unless you're on
like 300 acres or something or in a very
expensive corrective land
um uh an unusual property you wouldn't A
good rule of thumb in the building world
is don't let your lot be more than about
20 of the total picture interesting okay
and so and so if you had a half a
million dollar project total then you
wouldn't want your lot to be more than a
hundred thousand that's good twenty
percent of that and so um and she's
she's right around 20 is where she ends
up so again it ends if the lot's paid
for it ends up having the net effect to
her question of having put down 20 right
because her mortgage is she's going to
have more than a 20 or or less than an
eighty percent loan to value more than
20 Equity so she's going to avoid PMI
private mortgage insurance it's the same
rule that we would say for any other
regular purchase but this involves a
construction loan with a permanent
mortgage as a takeout yeah yeah and so
that's that's very very good it's a very
standard transaction there's nothing to
be afraid of here that's a very normal
process the construction loan will not
increase except as you pay the Builder
and the Builder will not get paid unless
they meet certain Milestones they'll get
a certain amount at the foundation
they'll get another certain amount when
they finish the framing they'll get
another certain amount when the roofing
goes on when the rough end is done on
the Mechanicals and so there's about
five in a typical construction there's
about five break points as the
construction goes along they'll issue a
little bit more a little bit more put
you a little bit more in debt but the
house is a little bit more higher
percentage of completion sure and so
it's doled out to the Builder and it's
very standardized it's very careful they
you know they're not going to do it
unless they can prove that the framing
package is up yeah you know Builder
doesn't get draws on something that
hasn't happened in other words
so and then you don't end up in a in a
pinch so uh that's where we're going
that's a really good question Dale it is
the thing A lot of people are looking at
right now in this world today so very
fun very fun
love it love it love it Jade warshaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us America Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today
if you're new to all this Ramsey stuff
and we know some of you are a bunch of
you are based on our increase in ratings
our increase in rankings recently
one way to find out what in the flip
we're talking about
is go to ramseysolutions.com and click
on the get started button
we'll help you figure out exactly where
you are and what your next best steps
are
and we'll plug you into your plan your
journey and you'll start learning some
of the lingo from around here some of
the vernacular
and we'll show you how to go in with
this we literally have shown Millions
how click get started it's free
at Ramsey Solutions
.com Brad's in Denver hey Brad welcome
to the Ramsay show
hey Dave thanks for making my uh making
time to make uh take my call sure how
can we help
um well thank you so much I uh my
question is is
um I've got about 650 000 in cash wow in
the bank and um where'd you get that
well we uh we actually saved a lot of it
and part of it was inheritance as well
so
um the the big thing for me is I've been
listening for years for years and I know
that you said hey take it slow and
really educate yourself on you know what
you want to do with money and so I I've
scheduled uh an appointment with one
year investor Pro uh investors here
locally but I also my wife and I have
been wanting to start a business of Our
Own in commercial real estate
specifically in self-storage and I don't
want to use all of it I just want to use
a certain percentage of it as part of
the diversification strategy and then
the other part of it in Investments and
so I just wanted to get your thoughts on
you know the best way
of how to I guess diversify that amount
of money okay
how long have you had this inheritance
like when did you receive it
um about two years ago okay so you've
sat on it for a while
so um tell me about the Self Storage
thing
my parents uh had their own business and
um actually had
um some commercial buildings
um that they operated and probably about
10 years ago they handed it over to uh
the kids including myself my brother and
sister so I'm actually uh 30 33 owner in
that and um and so learned a lot about
commercial real estate in that but we're
very conservative we just kind of keep
that separate one of the buildings that
we had
um we sold and so part of the proceeds
we as kids got distributions from that
and that was really kind of just an
opportunity for us to or at least my
dad's heart was hey is this can help you
accelerate your retirement strategy in
your plan yeah but I haven't moved
forward with it because I don't wanna
but as far as doing mini storage or Self
Storage
what what price range are you looking at
a property
well the big thing I was thinking of is
an RV boat storage facility so you know
just understanding you know if it's a
couple acres maybe worth uh a half a
million to maybe a million dollars I'm
still doing research
but I think the thought is is that if if
you can put about 65 units on one acre
of land
um the work generates maybe about a
hundred thousand dollars maybe a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars of gross
revenue
you know after expenses I think the net
operating income that we've kind of
looked at would probably be half of that
um and so you know part of it is kind of
the strategy and the thought of you're
talking about buying a piece of property
with debt
yeah either acquire one or actually
um buy a piece of land and then build it
up from there okay
well I um own a bunch of commercial real
estate I own a bunch of residential real
estate I don't borrow money you probably
knew that though didn't you
yes okay
so I'm not going to instruct you as a
method of Building Wealth to take half
of your 650 000 or half of your seven
hundred thousand and put it into a down
payment no I would not do that
um I would pay cash for the property I'm
a fan of Self Storage uh the the cash uh
the cash on cash Returns on it are
astronomical a little higher hassle
Factor than a lot of rentals and there's
certainly a lot of commercial property
but um you basically got to have
somebody running it is you know in most
cases
um I have some pretty incredible
technology one of the two and and we've
looked at both
um looked at a couple of those deals for
ourselves as a matter of fact but we pay
cash for Investments Brad so
um that's going to change the discussion
here
um uh because I'm not going to tell you
to go into debt to do this because as
you know things don't always work the
way they work when you lay them out on
paper that's true I mean he talked about
splitting up the money and doing some
towards Investments and some on the
storage I wonder if he just said I'm
going to go all in on the storage and
find some you know find a piece that's
half a million he said half a million to
a million so maybe if you can find the
one that's half a million yeah you can
pay cash pay cash and then put 700 000 I
mean put the other you know yeah put a
hundred thousand improvements in that
100 000 mutual funds and then just take
your cash flows and let's let's build
that cash back up with the cash flows
that's not a bad idea there
um uh especially since you're dealing
with if you're dealing with boat and RV
storage uh you're not dealing a ton of
improvements usually it's just a chain
link fence yeah so
um but yeah I that that's probably the
angle I would end up going here Brad
because I'm going to have to figure out
a way to do the the type of deal that I
want to do but do it with all cash I
don't borrow money and I'm not going to
tell you to do something I wouldn't do
that's also going to make his his
um revenue and what he he's earning off
of that because he said Gross he'd pull
in about 150 and then he'd keep half of
it so if he's not having to if he's not
mortgaging anymore
yeah exactly good point all right Anselm
is with us in San Jose hey Anselm how
are you
doing all right thank you God how can we
help
um
I've been just trying to figure out like
the whole investment process
um and kind of I'm kind of in the
process of the uh you know investing 15
of uh income and or trying to buy a
house I live in the you know one of the
most expensive places in the United
States yeah sure do so even a decent
house is like a million dollars plus so
um how old are you should I in uh 29
what do you make uh
uh well it keeps increasing kind of a
lot last year was uh about 144 in this
year's uh about I'm gonna guess about
170 180. good good for you what do you
do
accounting Revenue excellent
so what's the question exactly
um well
I'm I'm able to save you know a decent
amount of money
but it's like you know down payment
uh is is a lot yeah
um and
um
are you just discouraged because it's
going to take you a while
yeah it's like it could take five years
um I maybe could reduce it by year if I
invest last do you have a family it's
just you
uh it's me and my wife you and your wife
um
what dish and then so
the 170 is that including her income or
is that just yours
that's basically just mine okay well
what does she make she
she uh is potentially gonna make
round 140 if she can get a nursing job
so she's not working yet definitely
not working out yeah all right is she
just finishing nursing school
yeah she just finished if she can get a
nursing job in about 20 seconds yeah she
passes her board she's going to be
employed as soon as she wants to be now
you got a 300 350 000 household income
shut up and save a down payment save it
up it's just the two of you guys and
it's gonna take some time you're not
going to get you know you're not going
to be done in six months it might take a
little bit you know it's going to take
longer but here's the thing you want the
house so the time is going to pass
anyway so just start saving up start
cutting expenses and you might have to
kind of depending on how quickly you
want this to go you can decide how
intense you want to get with this I mean
you can go scorched Earth or you can
just go la Tida you know and make it a
stroll in the park and it's going to
take you five years yeah I mean you can
make it take you 10 years yeah you can
make it take you just a couple of years
too you guys are making bank yes you're
an expensive Market but you also have
two excellent careers you're doing a
great job of earning and now what you're
facing is oh we want to do big girl and
big boy stuff like buy houses instead of
play oh we have to stop the playing so
we can do that oh there it is this is
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today
Madeleine's with us in St Louis hi
Madeline welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
I am losing faith
um excuse me
I just feel like this is never going to
end this debt is so big
and and I'm just I'm frustrated and I
want to do it that pre-scream so bad and
it just it feels like it will never come
how can I keep going
how long you been in this Madeline
well also often for like five years but
we
beat thousand this year way to go it
feels eighty thousand in one year
we my husband we had saved a bunch my
husband had a great paying job we've
been working hard both of us but I just
don't know that I can do this for
another two years potentially hmm how
much debt have you got left
we have 221 000 in student loans and 120
000 on our mortgage okay your mortgage
is not in the intense side so you've got
the 221 to deal with what do you guys
make currently have 221 in student loans
I do mine alone we paid off my husband's
this year this last month actually very
good what do you all do for a living
I'm a chiropractor I'm self-employed and
he's a nurse
so what's your household income
last year we
grossed
what will you make this year
he is in between jobs and so and my
income fluctuates and that's the hardest
part why is he in between jobs he's a
nurse
is he um he
was very well paid so now he's waiting
to hear for another job that is a local
travel so that he can be home every
night how long has he been waiting
um he just applied this past week he
accepted a position he's waiting for a
religious exemption to go through so he
does not have to get vaccinated
how long has he been waiting
um two days how long has he been out of
work
and he's not currently out of work he's
working weekends part-time right now
until he gets this full-time thing
so okay so the facts are that he hasn't
lost much income
no okay so the facts are you guys are
going to make 300K this year
two no there's no reason you shouldn't
no
no you are
okay yeah
you can't let you know all these ifs
sends and buts the the fact is you got a
job and of course your income fluctuates
you're self-employed but that didn't
change
and the fact is he's a nurse which means
he can get employed in about 30 seconds
and he just proved that
yes yeah so the fact is you're not in
trouble at all you got a stinking 300
000 potential income it's amazing way to
go
and you've been guilt you said you've
been gazelle intense for one year right
um just here actually just the last
couple of months oh so you're gonna be
right on track from the point of view
getting gazelle intents you're going to
be right on track with everybody else
who's you know debt free in 18 to 24
months okay so I'm I'm
um
a little bit confused or something that
you're not telling us
well I want to know about the
should they been at this first you know
I think you said four or five years but
you just you just got intense I want to
know about those years what was going on
with them
my husband just got on board this year
we we started Financial Peace at the
beginning stop stop saying here's what
I'm struggling with and you need to help
me okay
you make three hundred thousand dollars
a year
your husband's got its new job and you
have 221 to go you've just proven that
you can do 80 000 in what period of Time
how long did that take
about four months good God yeah okay so
we just did 80 000 in four months and um
four months is not exactly I'm out of
steam and I've lost hope I don't
understand where this the tears and the
I'm not saying you shouldn't have them I
just don't understand where it's coming
from why would you be hopeless you
should be like Rocky right now you paid
off eighty thousand dollars you make 300
you should be like doing a touchdown
dance I know so what where's all this
where's all this hopelessness come from
how to
kind of financial piece we sold the
truck we had a little in savings that's
what gave us that's what you're supposed
to do at the beginning I'm not saying
you can maintain 80 over four months but
we know we can maintain 150 over a year
yeah
if you make 300 and you lived on 150
that'd be 150 towards debt in a year
which you can do in your area
yes
yes feels like I'm giving my
money hey you better yeah
you better give your life to it
I know hold on hold on hold on here it
is
you're tired from before
you were tired from before trying to get
your husband on board and and you're
letting that make you tired now but that
was gone that's in the past and now you
guys have a new lease on life he's on
board he's on the plan you did you got
intense you paid off eighty thousand
dollars and don't forget what I just
told you now you're just like everybody
else you're on the 18 to 24 months plan
you can live on 150 and put the other
150 on your debt and you're going to be
out of this in no time this is the walk
there's not an easy button to press uh
Madeline this is the walk there is
sacrifice there is you do feel tired I I
can't you can't wave a wand and get out
of that part but um there is real hope
absolutely I mean if you can't be out of
debt in 24 months making 300 and you
can't pay off 100 a year 150 a year for
two years and be done in 24 months I I
mean we somebody needs to come smack you
you need to do this this is doable the
math is doable
this is not hopeless at all when you
started this I thought you were going to
tell me you made 22 000 a year and owed
400 I didn't know this way it sounded
but this is not hopeless at all the math
on this is easy yeah but it's you I mean
yes you're signing up for a pain in the
butt 18 to 24 but at least you'll be
free forever when you finish forever yes
you can do this
okay this is really really doable but I
think Jade's right and is she right
you're tired from before not from now
yes
yeah because this last go-round you
ain't done enough to be tired yeah no
she was pulling him up the hill before
she was rolling a a pushing them out
nurse weight yes that's
what now hooray
and together now to the extent that is
not on board or you're not sure he's on
board that would give me pause I would
be hopeless then
I would be crying then
because if you got to drag him all the
way through this you may not get through
it you've already figured that part out
right
I think it's just we I know this is the
beginning of a very long you know it
feels the days feel so long yeah how old
are you we're doing 18 31. do you have
kids
what were you doing when you were 29 do
you even remember
okay that's two years ago
yeah two years in the scope of your
life's not spit yes it's going to be
hard but yes it's going to be worth it
and yes it's doable and the time is
going to pass anyway and that's the
question you have to ask yourself are
you going to wake up a year and a half
two years from now and you can wake up
two years from now and be in the exact
same spot you're in now or wake up two
years from now and be finished and
that's where you need to put your mind
imagine waking up two years from now
Madeline having decided it's too hard
we're not going to do it and you still
got 221 more because it's student loans
and the interest is going to come back
and it's going to tally up so here's
what's happening right this second Jade
and I can see this math and are more
excited for you than you are for you
yes right this second I mean that's what
we're trying to translate for you we're
trying to zip some of that excitement
over on your side of the aisle yeah
because you need you need a little zip
of that and we love you we want you to
win yes you're signing up for two years
of hard or if you don't do it you're
signing up for 20 years of hard yeah
we're yelling at you because we know you
can do it and we don't want you to I can
see that I can see it very clearly where
you're going to be if you and your
husband both stick with this you both do
beans and rice rice and beans you stop
the vacations and the eating out we have
job one and that's evict this ugly old
woman from your house named Sally May
she needs to go she's got a wart on the
end of her nose she's a she's a she's a
squatter in the bedroom she needs to go
we need to throw her on her can in the
street
that's where she needs to go and it's
War baby it's War
and you need to declare war and get
energy out of that and kick that old
woman out you can do it the numbers say
you can do it so put all the past tired
behind you embrace the 18 to 24 war and
get her done you can do this this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage and
Studios it's the Ramsay show where we
help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsay personality is my co-host
today open phone's a triple eight eight
two five five two two five eight eight
two five five two two five Susie is with
us in Wyoming hi Susie welcome to the
Ramsey Show
Hi how are you better than I deserve how
can we help
um
[Music]
I my husband passed away about 18 months
ago oh and my Lord how long were y'all
married honey
um he passed away the day after our 23rd
anniversary wow I'm so sorry what
happened to him
um he had covid oh
child was he
um 43. sorry to hear that oh my God
that's tough
oh baby girl how can we help you today
um well
we were
passed in
[Music]
what to do with anything money-wise now
yeah so I'm just hoping for some advice
where do I even start
are you are you working
yes I'm a head start teacher I teach
preschool okay so what do you make
um contracted I make about 34 000 a year
last year we had a few bonuses because
of covid stuff so
um last year was 42 000 but
how much have we got in Bill how much do
you have in debt not counting the house
um the only that I have is my student
loans that's about it's just over 27
000. okay do you rent or how do you own
the house
I rent how much is your rent
about 900 it's 900 a month okay
where is level Wyoming what's that close
to next major city
um
um we're right up by the border of
Montana
um Billings Montana okay if you're
familiar with that yes ma'am okay
trying to think how I can get how we can
get our arms around you and help you
walk through this okay
um so um
the good news is that uh
we can show you how to do this
um and it's not rocket science you don't
have to go get a master's degree in
finance
you just have to say
um I want to learn how to handle money
and I'm going to do what it takes to do
that
because there's going to be changes
involved okay
anytime we're not managing an area of
our life and we start to manage that
area of our life it is an emotional
strain you know what I'm saying
yes like I ran into one of my guys who's
one of our um senior guys on our
technology team downstairs a while ago
and he's lost 68 pounds
pretty impressive I told him I said man
you look like you lost a Backstreet Boy
and so uh pretty incredible you know and
uh but you know what to do that he had
to dramatically change his food intake
agreed
yes and change his exercise regime
agreed and to do all of that means that
change
over what he was doing is emotional
emotionally hard work
and you're gonna have to do some of that
are you okay with that
yes we can show you how to do it you've
just gonna have to do it and it's it's
at first learning a new skill of
anything learning a new skill of him
eating less or you managing money for
the first time is strenuous until you've
done it a while and then it's not
strenuous at all it's automatic that's
right well yeah because initially you're
going against the grain of what you used
to do or what's habitual for you to do
or what you know to do but we're going
to teach you things that are going to be
contrary to that but ultimately they're
going to be the best habits for you and
I'm guessing we're going to give you
Financial Peace absolutely absolutely we
have a nine-week class called Financial
Peace University we're going to give it
to you okay we're also going to give you
what's called every dollar which is the
world's best budgeting app and it
connects to your bank and it's how
you're going to do your budget because
from today on you're going to tell money
what to do instead of being stressed
when it left
you're going to make it behave
it's a misbehaving kid a misbehaving dog
and you're going to tell it to go the
the dog to go to the corner and sit and
it's going to learn to sit you're going
to make it behave you know what I'm
saying
because it feels kind of like it's wild
like it's out of control right now
doesn't it
yes like it's hard to conquer this thing
and you're going to rise up above it and
make it behave and we're going to show
you how it's doable but um that that
budget is how you're going to do that
among other things giving every dollar
an assignment before the month begins
and here's what's going to happen it's
going to be very weird for you you're
going to get a sense of peace and a
sense of power
over this money thing that you've never
had in your life if you'll do the stuff
we teach you
okay you can do it you can do it anybody
that can handle kindergartners can
handle money
they're a lot harder than money because
money money does what it's told it
doesn't have any drama it just does what
it's told
okay kindergartners are full on body
drama and so um it's true yeah for real
so the second thing I'm going to do is
we're going to put you on hold you're
going to sign up for sign you up we're
going to pay for it for Financial Peace
University for every dollar plus and
then we're also going to pay for I think
we've got one of our Ramsey coaches in
Billings
and uh oh and we will get a personal
coach for you to sit down with you and
walk you through all of this as well and
all of it's at no charge to you okay
oh thank you yeah so uh and and here's
the thing you can do this
is the most heartbreaking hard time
you've ever been through in your whole
life I suspect
yes yeah I'm so sorry
but the the good that'll come out of it
is you're going to get control of money
for the first time in your life
and we can do that for you and that will
add peace to the other areas of your
life that's why we call our program
Financial Peace
yeah if we show you how to do all of it
are you going to do it
uh yes I will I'm I'm already committed
okay good good well we'll take care of
you and Susie we're here to help you
anytime you call us as many times as you
need to call that coach that we're going
to set you up with as many times as you
need to you go through those lessons as
many times as you need to there's nine
lessons in nine weeks you can go through
them all you can binge them you can go
back through them back through them
sometimes it takes a little while and
stay connected to us too listen to the
show get in on that Facebook baby steps
community and surround yourself with
people who are doing what you're doing
if you're not plugged into a good church
get in one those of us that call
ourselves Christians one of the the
mandates of the good book is to take
care of widows and orphans
and that's one of the things we've been
doing here for the last five minutes
so we're here for you kiddo I'm so sorry
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
hey if you like what you hear please
subscribe to the show follow the show
leave a five-star review for the show
and share the show when you do all of
those things it helps us
we need your help
it's a way you can help us we appreciate
you let people know that we're here
gunzola or gonzala is with us gonzala
how are you
it's all good how are you better than I
deserve how can I help
well thank you for what you do um I am
six months into a cash value insurance
policy I'm sorry my policy
yeah uh this was before I started
hearing your podcast and
the way you feel about that
I did stop contributing to my 401
um to make the payments for this because
it's you know the premium is about a
thousand bucks oh gosh I do have some um
some of my 401 still
um you know I'm still contributing to it
which is the amount that my employer
matches so I'm taking advantage of that
so um I am six months into it and I
wanted to know if um
stick with it or you think I'm better
off cutting my losses and if you if you
had a suitcase of money laying in the
back seat and the back door flew open
and it was flying out what would you do
uh I'd probably stop it yeah yeah you
probably close the door
ended yes
that's what's going on you're getting
screwed man yeah big time it's the
world's worst
I mean the whole life is the payday
lender of the middle class
it's an absolute horrible set of
mathematics it's the worst investment
product on the market by far the only
people correct that sell this stuff
are the people that sell this stuff
they're the only people that believe in
it I mean all the rest of the financial
world looks at this and goes oh my God
and um it's just it's trash
so yeah you need to do your investing in
real Investments not in something that
has a poor rate of return and when you
die they keep your money and that's what
whole life is now this policy this whole
life policy before you do get out of it
we want to make sure that you get into a
term life policy at the very least have
you got good term insurance in place
already
I have about the same amount of benefit
a couple of separate uh policies so I I
don't necessarily have the need for it
um the the reason why I went with this
was an investment I mean that amount
tax-free correct and no taxes at the end
that was the selling point and that's
what got me
um you know why there's no taxes you
know why there's no taxes at the end
because you're making money
and they never tax you when you don't
make money
okay so if you put money in a mutual
fund and it does not go up in value
there's no taxes at the end
correct if it goes down in value there's
no taxes at the end if they take so many
fees out of it that the net net net net
to you is no gain there's no taxes at
the end oh and by the way when you
borrow money even if it's your own money
you're borrowing which is what a whole
life is borrowed money never has taxes
you go get a loan at the bank they don't
give you a tax on that loan
there's no income tax on borrowed money
even if you're borrowing your own money
and so if you put a CD in the bank and
then you go borrow against the CD
and take out a loan there's no taxes on
that
of course there's no taxes on borrowed
money so that's the biggest scam in the
freaking Universe there's no taxes of
course there's no taxes because it sucks
yeah they don't usually charge you on
something that sucks this bad yeah
please please please cancel this stuff
please cancel I hope I haven't been
unclear all right Matt is in Baton Rouge
hey Matt how are you
I'm doing well sir thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
a quick question some are relatively new
listener and I started listening just in
time to hear you talk about the bank
craziness going on and I'm just curious
this might be a really stupid question
but how can the FDIC
ensure every deposit under 250
000 where do they get the money in I'm
not even exactly sure what the FDIC is
can you use like a brief crash course
rundown sure it stands for Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation
it's the federal government
writing insurance
against your bank's failure
now do they have a pile of money equal
to everyone's covered amount absolutely
not but your insurance company does not
have a pile of money equal to everyone
at State Farm totaling their car this
week either
if everybody totaled their car at once
State Farm's gone
they don't have that much money okay
what they're running is they're running
probabilities statistical probability of
this occurring uh and so if enough Banks
went down at one time to destroy the
amount of money that the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation the
federal government could get their hands
on uh that means the entire American
economy has collapsed and you should buy
a gun
gotcha gotcha so it's it's publicly
funded no well it Matt think of it like
how how your insurance works if you have
State Farm everybody's paying their
premium and they're paying into this big
pile of money so that when somebody
needs to actually use their insurance
there's money there and it's the same
thing with FDIC these insured banks are
paying premiums to FDIC okay so there's
a big stack of money
the banks fund the FDIC with their
premiums but they don't give it enough
money to cover all bank failures that
simultaneously occurring no
but
it's plenty to cover anything that's
actually going to occur but if uh but
but the mathematics are to your point
Matt uh the mathematics are just like if
all of State Farm Autos had a got
totaled in one month they would there's
not enough they don't have the money to
cover all that because they're running
it on probabilities and so this is an
insurance policy based on a you know a a
projected number of bank failures in a
given decade and plus a lot and so it's
a very conservative set of mathematics
meaning you could have a whole bunch of
banks fail we had a lot of them cashed
out FDIC and and went Belly Up FDIC took
them over resold the banks the sale of
the bank the money goes back into the
insurance policy as well to cover but um
that happened in 2008 a lot more than in
the last in the last three or four
months or so so but if you had um
twenty five thousand Banks crash at one
time there's not enough money and by the
way if twenty five thousand Banks crash
at one time we got issues Life as We
Know It in America no longer exists
that's right there's a whole lot of
other crap that goes with that that
can't be just an independent thing yeah
you got to understand that if that
occurs everywhere you shop is out of
business oh yeah we're looking for clean
water and and supplies it's not yeah
yeah we're not we're not looking for
gold
yeah that's exactly what we're doing so
that that but it's a good question it's
good something to think about so
um and it's good that you know we do a
little bit of educational occasionally
here Jason's in Dallas Texas hi Jason
how are you
hey how are you today better than we
deserve how can we help
appreciate you taking the call and
condolences to your college Susie as
well that was really sweet that you did
for thank you um liquor losing our
husband so
um you know I have I have some issues
and I have some kind of questions I'm
sure that you did to the questions
through the issues but um a few years
ago probably four years ago my wife and
I picked up and moved from our home in
Los Angeles we moved out to Texas
um it was about a year before the
pandemic I felt like something was going
to happen I'm just seeing where La had
was going to be rude but I am up against
the clock go ahead and just ask me your
question
so we have a new business and a new baby
a lot of debt
um
when I had the baby last year I was
trying to pay us you know a top salary
but I feel like I'm now bleeding my
first baby which is this new business
um I'm trying to get my real estate
license to supplement some income
but what do I sell what do I get rid of
to prioritize
the debt while also keeping up with this
big new
this big new thing in my life which is
was just trying to raise a new kid amen
well very cool hey we're going to put
you guys through financial Pace
University too because I am up against
the clock I'll make sure you get served
okay but in the meantime you got big
hairy car payments get rid of the big
hairy car uh you need to prioritize very
carefully and keep that business running
because it's the golden gooses laying
the eggs but don't leave a bunch of
extra money down there and don't do a
bunch of reinvestment down there take it
home and clean up the mess at home it's
a balancing act between the two I wish I
could give you more detailed answer hang
on Austin will pick up for you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back Ed by their
one guarantee and shipping is always
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 percent off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
'd wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five there's a new
movement in the
Financial world the banking world
to do advertising with a narrative of
how much they're here to help
when a bank says they're here to help
you should act like the government
saying they're here to help okay you
should say oh my gosh I mean so let me
give you an example if you you know Sofi
spent 300 million dollars last year on
marketing and advertising with sweet
little people
on the screen going we're trying to get
out of debt and we're working our way
out of debt do you know what sofa does
they shall doubt
hello is this thing on
hello are you out there you know what we
call that Dave we call that a catfish
definitely that's a catfish with no
mustard yes catfish with no mustard
parading around as one thing when really
you're it's like a wolf in sheep's
clothing yep
it's like a cat pretending to be a fish
just saying yeah you're exactly right on
the catfishing thing catfishing on uh on
Instagram will get you banned from
people's lives that's right catfishing
when you're a bank is a way of doing
business man
here's another one here's another one
rocket mortgage oh
they're fast they're a rocket
we gotta get into this rocket mortgage
this is the headline that came across
our desk this is so great rocket
mortgage launches a credit card
to help you save or pay off your home
which everyone knows that works I mean
it's really let's be honest Dave it was
only a matter of time so they no I mean
I when you're sitting there in the
meeting with the Ad Agency
what are you guys smoking
that comes up with this byline for a
press release because this is a byline
from a press release the CNBC then
picked up rocket mortgage launches a
credit card to help you did anybody not
go this is like standing in traffic will
not get you killed
oh gosh it's a saving up for a down
payment and closing costs is a major
hurdle on the path to home ownership oh
boohoo the new credit card from mortgage
lender rocket companies aims to help
buyers eliminate it so they're saying
hey you know what it's not going to be
hard anymore it's not going to be hard
you can use a credit card you just
borrow your down payment on our credit
card you can earn lots of points oh five
x points on and oh here I love it
because now the dumb people in the world
are going to go 5x points yes I
definitely want to put my down you know
my down payment on my credit card
because I get 5x points on it and guess
what you get to do with the points
pay down the mortgage wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute the dog just
Chase its tail the dog chased it yeah
yeah he's going in circles
we got points that aren't real anything
to use to pay down on the mortgage to
cover the down payment that we didn't
make because we used the credit card to
get the points
it's like when you go to the carnival
and they go which which cup is it under
and they moved and they move it where's
the pee boys and girls wow I'll tell you
where it is rocket mortgage is peeing on
you that's where it is oh my God it says
okay so five you this is what you get if
you sign up for the rocket Signature
Visa card you get five rocket reward
points on all purchases this sounds like
I'm in kindergarten I know right I get
Rockets Mommy I got three rockets today
and this is probably the one that it
just sounds dumb it just we're talking
about down payments mortgage payments
real money here and it says but you get
the 95 you know dollar service fee
waived
all right you get 95 guys great
they waived their fee that's too high
yeah
annual fee is 95 but they've you know
what I'm I'm gonna wave my fee too
um I didn't have one until a few minutes
ago but now I've got one and I'm gonna
wave it I'm not gonna charge you guys to
listen to the show it was going to be a
hundred dollars but we're gonna wait
we're just gonna wave You're such great
customers we all are amazing and so
we're just gonna wave that here we go
intro APR none but the regular APR
I don't know if I can even say this
without screaming it
20.49 and it's variable so it can go up
to 30.49 APR which just stands for added
pain and regret all right you're you're
using your credit card
to pay down your home loan at his pain
and regret that's good at thirty point
four nine percent variable you may as
well have went out and just
oh gosh this is the worst thing I've
seen in a long long time Dave
well credit needed not specified
yeah
um this is
the thing about this is it's so funny
because it's not even subtle it's just
it's just pretty much announcing we're
gonna screw you and here's how and
you're gonna you're gonna like it
they're not even you're gonna enjoy it
this is they're not even trying to I
mean when they said credit needed not
specified there to help you
yes we're here to help you James said in
the booth he said this sounds very
incestuous I said yes because we're
we're getting you
rocket mortgage we're getting you the
loan that you could never afford in the
first place and then because we know you
could never afford it in the first place
we're going to help you by giving you a
credit card so you can put the down
payment on that you could never afford
in the first place and help you pay the
payment that you could never afford in
the first place and we're just we're
good guys we're here for you I thought
he meant when he said incestors that
your parents had to be cousins for you
to fall for this that might be true too
that might be true you need to be
missing brain cells in order to think
that this is a good idea this is on
freaking believable oh man oh man oh man
guys y'all aren't even bashful about
screwing your customers I mean you just
come right out and say it we're just
gonna do it like 30 percent interest
yeah right there man just step up we got
you back man
wow it's just is there is no limit to
their but there is a generous reward
rate on all purchases there's lots of
generosity involved here
I just I smell generosity all over this
wow yeah this is a steaming pile of you
know what catfish catfish rotten catfish
Mary's in Charlotte North Carolina hey
Mary welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave how are you doing today better
than I deserve how are you
good so I had a question
um I have sixty thousand dollar debt and
a credit card a few credit cards and uh
wanted to find out what would be
I guess the fastest or best way to pay
that off just because the interest rates
are so high
sixty thousand dollars or you're gonna
get sixty thousand dollars interest
rates not your problem spending more
than you make your problem
he's not wrong what do you make
uh my husband in 990. good there you go
how much your car payment
uh uh 300 a month
what about the other car
same 300 both of them 300 600 so what do
you owe on these two cars
um each one of them is 15
000 and the other one is 12. and 60 in
credit card debt and how much in student
loans
none good what other debt
house Medical
none
what am I leaving out other than the
house
lawnmower
um
no sir just that's it so that just means
y'all need to get your spending under
control you need to get on a written
budget yeah are you on a budget yet
nope so we are we just paid off 50 000
last year wow well that's good that's
good well that's suspiciously close to
65 000.
15 more right so if you did it once
before you can do it again
right we're doing the snowballing first
thing I know exactly what you need to do
interest rates not your problem very
good because if you pay the 60 000 off
in one year you're not got an interest
rate problem you cannot borrow your way
out of debt you're gonna have to come up
with sixty thousand dollars the way you
came up with fifty thousand dollars and
when you do that you will be debt free
other than these cars you're gonna get
them paid off too while we're doing this
so you just keep leaning in kiddo keep
leaning in you got the sauce now just
keep applying the sauce that's what we
do
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us hanging out with us
we're so glad you're here open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five folks uh if you've got a lot of
questions about taxes we get it taxes
are confusing to help you out uh we're
gonna unpack a question from one of our
listeners I'm confused about the new
standard deduction I'm head of household
with two dependents can you explain how
this works okay this year your standard
deduction 600 higher to quote adjust for
inflation unquote that means as a single
person you can subtract 19 4 from your
taxable income like an automatic text
write-off
compared to someone who's filing single
your standard are you you can do that as
a head of household your standard
deduction is higher and your tax rate is
lower mainly to offset the cost of
caring for dependents now you can choose
to itemize your deductions instead of
taking the standard deduction uh by the
way if you're married filing jointly
it's about 28 000 and um and so unless
you have write-offs itemized write-offs
in excess of the standard deduction you
take the standard deduction now let me
tell you what that means
last year 88 percent of Americans took
the standard deduction
only 12 percent
did a c Schedule C which means you're
taking write-offs okay so you'd have to
have large write-offs you to losses
interest paid charitable giving or some
other kind of write-offs that total up
to more than the standard deduction or
you wouldn't take the standard deduction
you'd be smarter to take the standard
deduction so if you got ten thousand
dollars in write-offs you do that so
that's one of the things Jade that
people say I don't pay my home off I
lose the write-off you're not using the
write-off anyway duber
right because you're taking the standard
deduction and if you're taking the
standard deduction you're right off on
your home means absolutely zero so
you're staying in debt for no stupid
reason
it's a good point that's what that
people just say that just it's vast
majority 88 last year took extended
reduction they do not itemize so if
you're ready to file your taxes check
out Ramsey smart tax it lets you file
online with upfront low pricing no
hidden fees you can save up to 70 when
you switch from another software which
would be a good idea head to
ramseysolutions.com smarttax
ramseysolutions.com
smarttax Jasmine is in Seattle hey
Jasmine welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Jay thank you so much for
taking me a call it's truly been a
godsend finding the show
you're welcome so I am a new first-time
mom to a five-month-old baby boy oh
congratulations realized thank you
um I just realized so after finding your
show that my husband and I are in a
scary spot financially uh so my husband
makes 70 000 a year as an ICU nurse and
I just transitioned to be a stay-at-home
mom and we have 140 000 in debt so my
husband just started picking up overtime
so we can start the debt snowball he's
working 60 hours a week now in the ICU
and I want to do the best I can to
support him and our family and tackling
this mountain so I was thinking of
trying to find freelance work to do
during naps and evenings but I'm worried
if that's the right thing so my question
is would it be better for me to try to
pick up freelance work for a little
extra or should I prioritize my role as
a wife and a caretaker to our son so
that my husband doesn't have any
household stress and has like the best
success at keeping up 60 hour weeks and
a high stress job to tackle our debt how
much debt do you have
140 000. on what
80 is in student loans and 60 is
Consumer Debt um credit cards and
personal loans
um
that have accumulated over the last
seven years no car loan
no car loan and what can you what can
you make freelancing
um I'm thinking that I could uh get
about 600 a month if I did 10 hours
which uh I think I would have with like
nap times anything
so explain your hesitation so if you
were to take two hours out of your
evening and do a little bit of side work
10 hours a month
or 10 hours a week sorry oh a week okay
all right go ahead I'm sorry no that's
all right I mean are you just worried
that you aren't being a good mom or
something or that you're not going to be
able to take care of the house the way
you want to for your husband is that
what I'm hearing
yeah so he does like 12-hour shifts
um so I right now typically make the
dinner I put my little one to bed and
he's five months so I know in the first
year a lot of things can change so I
guess I'm worried to even get started in
case like I get too stressed out doing
it or if I end up like not having enough
time to do that and like take care of
the household like I guess I think it's
a worry that I think it's a fear that's
existing because you're not it's unknown
so at the very least if it were me I
would try it I would try to work and see
if I can juggle it if you guys have both
decided hey it's important for us to be
as intense as possible about this debt
so we're both going to sacrifice we're
both understanding that this might be a
Chaotic season of our life and if you
start it and you're making the money and
at the end of the day you're like man
you know these few hundred dollars that
I'm bringing it is not worth XYZ if you
figure that out and then maybe you have
to Pivot to another strategy I say try
it and then it's not just this fear
looming over you of I'm afraid to try it
but if I don't you know the other thing
is there's no reason for this to stress
anybody out you might get tired but
there's no reason to be stressed true
that all you gotta do is just plan it
you say this is what we're doing
here's the details okay on this night
I'm going to cover this and you're not
on that night you're going to cover it
and I'm not and this is the system this
is the process this is the schedule it's
going to suck but so does being deeply
in debt and I can add 30k to the Top
Line of this situation you're making 70
that's a hundred we can knock this out
twice as fast if we lean into this
together and we say okay there's a big
old pile of dishes here how we getting
the dishes clean we both got to get in
here we both got to pick apart and we
take a process and we lay a system in
and one dries and once puts them in the
dishwasher and here we go and we just
get the dishes clean and that's what
you're doing you're just laying into the
work yep and you're doing it with detail
and there's no reason for stress again
you're going to get tired but oh well
you've got a baby you're going to be
tired that just goes with the territory
and something tells me I don't know if
I'm right Jasmine but something tells me
this one kid is probably not your only
there might be another one coming up
down the pipe and you for sure won't be
rid of this debt for them exactly
exactly because then your time is gonna
be strong stretched even thinner so
yeah that's what I'm doing yeah
systems and scheduling and lots of
communication and agreement makes the
stress go away it doesn't make the
fatigue go away but it makes the stress
go away
how's that sound
I I think that's a doable I was leaning
towards like just trying it because you
can always like change but I think it
was just the fear that was there yeah
but don't try it without laying out a
detailed game plan
give it a fair shot a detailed game plan
you and your husband sit down TV off kid
in bed this is okay we're gonna lay this
out I'm gonna try this here's the nights
I'm gonna do Freelancers what I'm doing
boom boom boom here's your days here's
what Saturday looks like here's what
Sunday looks like here's what the days
off look like whatever it is and you
just lay it out and go okay we're going
to lean into this for a short period of
time and you know Sharon and I have
learned you know one of the reasons that
I've been able to become so successful
in business is because she and I plan in
detail calendars and money yes we budget
time and money and we're in detailed
agreement and that way I don't get home
and and I'll say I'm gonna be home at 5
30 and I come wandering in at 6 30. I
you know the number of times I don't
show up when I said I was going to is
very close to zero that's good deal it's
not because I'm some kind of Stellar
person it's a plan you know we planned
it and I'm you know I know today a when
I get off the air I'm going to do I've
got three social media things and five
commercials to record and then I'm
heading to the house so I know where I'm
going to be if something blows up and I
need to stay here and work I can email
her and say I'm going to be running 10
minutes late but but I know where I'm
going to be it's already planned yeah
and so you can plan out where you're
going to be and then you're not freaked
out it's kind of you know what it's like
the week before you go on vacation
you're not stressed
you got a million things to do you get
two weeks worth of done two weeks worth
of work done before the week of vacation
because you're trying to get it all
aligned right right but it's all
processing systems okay I see where it
took me a minute to see where you're
going with that one Dave but I got you
now yeah I got you because you're going
I gotta get this knocked out and get
this knocked out so that I can be on
vacation and be free got you yes and you
you knock the crap out and you do that
you line it up and then knock the
dominoes over so the next week you know
when you're in Cabo you know you can
relax you know that's it yeah
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they really love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
thank you for jumping in Jake is with us
in Tampa Florida hi Jake welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave how are you today better than I
deserve what's up
um so I'm you know I've been following
the podcast and um I'm really ready to
grab you know the bull by the horns here
and really get cranking on uh this debt
that me and my wife has but I'm finding
that she's very fearful of the process
so much so where she's almost getting
paralyzed with deer and you know doing
nothing instead of you know getting
after it basically what's she afraid of
um she's afraid of Dipping into the
savings
um getting rid of our vehicles to you
know get cheaper ones worrying about
them breaking down you know a cheaper
vehicle breaking down that sort of thing
and you know I'm I'm really trying to
get going here she's fine with putting a
little bit of extra money towards credit
cards but anything major like that she
just she just can't
um seem to get past it so you've got a
you've got a lump of cash sitting there
that you've been saving up and you're
wanting to put it on the debt and that's
making her feel funky is that right yeah
well lump is a word for it it's only
about five thousand dollars but um
it's better than nothing
what was that how much you owe on your
car
well we have two trucks
um you're gonna kill me
39 000 loan on my pickup and we have
about 27 left on hers yeah what do you
guys make a year
you make about 130 A Year y'all are
freaking insane yeah
how old are you 26
uh 27 and my wife yeah like I've done
this before okay
wow
all right so what's happening is is that
you've recognized there's a problem and
that you're gonna that's a pretty ex
extreme problem and you're gonna have to
take some Extreme Measures to fix an
extreme problem and she hasn't even
recognized that there's an extreme
problem yet
yeah yeah I mean she knows there's a
problem
she does not think there is a problem
not like this oh we could pay a little
extra on the credit cards that doesn't
say there's a problem you guys are
freaking broke
you can't breathe
you got eighty thousand dollars worth of
stupid cars
mm-hmm
oh my God yeah I mean
wow no I'm not gonna kill you I'm crying
for you it's scaring me I'm more scared
than your wife is and it's not even my
house
those cars is that the only debt or is
there more laying around
we got the truck and then we have uh 21
000 in credit cards oh yeah well of
course you do because you can't pay your
bills because you have car payments so
my guess is a lot of her fear you guys
have never gone through financial peace
you're you're picking this up from
listening to the show is that
am I right yeah yeah you know my wife
used or um my mom used to have you know
Dave on the radio and I you know listen
here and there and I've you know I've
kind of realized the predicament that a
man and I realize I really need to do
something here so my guess is that she
you're just relaying this information to
her and she might be getting bits and
pieces of it but she's not maybe heard
it laid out in the way that she needs to
in order to kind of trust this process
and really see that there's a problem it
sounds like you've been listening and
your eyes are wide open and she's still
focused on yeah but I want to be
comfortable she's she's still seeing
comfort more than she's seeing like the
house is on fire she doesn't see that
yet
yeah she's like yeah I smell smoke but I
think you can put it out yeah and you
and I are like uh the house is burning
down around you uh-huh
yeah you know we sat down we did our
budget and you know she knows the
numbers and you know we we went through
all of that but it just
it just seems to be affecting me more
and uh yeah because she's seeing that as
normal you cannot you cannot start this
until she is
um
it is as informed and as enthused about
cleaning up this mess as you are because
it's you're it's simply not going to
work
because it's not that she's afraid it's
that she's uninformed she does she does
not understand where you all are she may
have glanced at the numbers but she has
not swallowed them and put them in her
heart because otherwise she'd have
heartburn mm-hmm
exactly yeah you guys need to sit down
and have a real conversation about this
and honestly you probably need to go
through Financial Peace University which
if Austin can pick up at the end of this
call he can give that to you because if
we give you that class nine week class
one class a week for nine weeks and even
if you took two a week for uh five weeks
and knocked it out well you started and
with her and can you get her to sit down
and watch this with you
um I can yes yes I can do it yeah okay
okay because it's better honey I need
you to do this as a favor to me this
stuff's driving me crazy you're not
worried about it but I can't sleep I
need your help please look at this with
me and let Dave and and John and and all
the other Personalities in there be the
one to drive this message home and let
them be the bad guy no it's not a bad
guy it's not a bad guy we're all on the
same team here we all want one thing and
that's for Jake and his wife to prosper
we want them to win yeah we love you we
want you to win we're not none of us are
bad guys you're not a bad guy she's not
a bad guy she just hasn't recognized
where she is yet that's right and once
she because I want her so fired up that
she's like Jake why haven't you already
sold your truck right but if if he's the
one going in every night and is like
honey we need to do this which she's
gonna be like so let us be the one to
tell her if she once she catches the
vision of this she doesn't have the
vision for it that's all it is and once
she catches the vision for it then it's
not fear fear is not the right word it's
she simply didn't want to do it
yeah she's not afraid she's just saying
no she likes being able to go and swipe
that credit card I like this I like this
30 000 car why would I not like it yeah
no until you figure out that your dad
gum right on the verge of bankruptcy
yeah nobody wants to go from a nice
forty thousand dollar card to a to an
old eight thousand like that doesn't
feel good but you gotta do it yeah I
mean when when your best idea is honey
we're gonna sell your car that usually
doesn't go well yeah so
um but yeah both of these cars got to go
and you all are going to get home beans
and rice and you're gonna learn to live
on listen you make you make too much
money to be this broke we need to get
both of you need to get disgusted once
you guys get out of these trucks this is
gonna go lickety-split these trucks are
the problem the credit cards are not
there because of credit card spending
the credit cards are there because they
can't afford to live after they pay
these truck payments yeah that's what it
is they're squeezed yeah that's been the
and we'll pick with the credit cards
picking up a slack so when there is no
slack but then boom you know you'll
knock them out and you're gonna you're
gonna have this mess cleaned up once you
get rid of these ridiculous vehicles
um but yeah you it's you have a truck
that needs to be amputated you have a
truck amputation coming in
amputate the Tahoe this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today I say this a lot if you celebrate
Friday too much it may be a sign that
you need to change what you're doing
Monday through Thursday if you feel
stuck
in a j-o-b
if your work is leaving you exhausted
and unfulfilled and burnt out well it
means you're doing something you hate
Ken Coleman's our expert in the world of
work and he's hitting the road to help
you finally find a job that you actually
enjoy and make more money it is possible
Ken's career breakthrough events they're
amazing he'll coach you in several
different areas whether finding a job or
how to get a raise or what's the bonus
or hey all of this and you get his
wildly popular get clear assessment when
you sign up for one of these
breakthrough events the first one is
April 20th in Kansas City
and then Chicago May 16th Atlanta May
18th in Dallas on May 23rd tickets are
50 get yours at ramsesolutions.com
events today Canada is next Abram is
with us hi Abram how are you
not too bad sir how are you better than
I deserve what's up
wonderful I'm just trying to wrap my
head around uh how to prioritize some
house rentals that need to happen
um now these host rentals are you know
they're more than your basic uh cosmetic
making it look good there are some
actual structural things but the houses
to actually sound it's not going to fall
down tomorrow so it's not a panic
structure but I'm thinking my gut
feeling is in the next five years to the
max 10 uh Max 10 years these these rooms
need to be dealt with I'm just trying to
wrap my head around what kind of funds
do we throw at this is it worth throwing
funds at it knowing that our eventual
goal is an acreage even though that that
price tag just seems so unachievable
um just kind of trying to prioritize
that we are on baby step two right now
just sold our our forty thousand dollar
dumb yesterday and paid the dump tax on
it
um
okay so what does the repairs cost
this is I'm going to be anywhere between
until we we deal with we're actually
dealing with some uh actual sub source
and some floor structure issues that's
translated into uh linoleum Kraken and
it sounds like you want to do that to
sell it anyway don't you
most likely yes
okay
what's the house worth fixed
probably around 200
what do you make
between 80 and 100. and how much is in
your baby step two
that's not a baby step two
okay uh
yeah we're just working through your
book right now don't have Money Makeover
heavy step two is all your debts except
the house working the debt snowball
listing them smallest to largest and
attacking them in that order
right okay so how much how much
non-house debt do you have
3 500 on the credit card
uh got eleven five in student loans and
15 and a line of credit
okay how long do you think it's gonna
take you to knock that out
I'm thinking we
um my guess is a year okay
well if I added that correctly as you
were saying it it's really close to
thirty thousand dollars isn't it
pretty near yep yeah so if you do that
in a year and then you're done in
another year you'd have the money for
the repairs
yeah
that's what I would do I mean you said
that these repairs are not like
life-threatening it's not like the house
is going to fall in a little bit more
than cosmetic right they can wait a year
yeah it's not like you just had this big
water damage and you've got to you know
do something this is what you want to do
to make the house look better is that
right
yeah yeah yeah
that's probably my own itch wherever I
live I got to make it better oh yeah you
need to hold off on that you got bigger
goals you got you got bigger goals to
focus on you got to just kind of you
know when you're sitting on the couch at
night just just look at the TV don't
look at the carpet don't look at how
much better the floors can be uh you
don't be looking at TV you need to be
working and getting this debt paid off
if you go even better Dave even better
yeah yeah work so much you're barely at
home try that one that works too so yeah
so you know a repair when you're in baby
step two that has to be done to
for safety or uh you know something
that's extreme yes we've got to stop and
do that
um but even in our case uh Jade when we
were going broke all those years ago we
had no money and we're working our way
through this stuff we had a leak in the
roof and it was dripping down the uh
light fixture over the kitchen table a
little scary
so I went over to the hardware store and
got some of that black tar stuff pretty
pretty white trashy yeah that I was
gonna say that's a uncle boo-boo pretty
much pretty much uh redneck Dave up
there on the roof smearing this this tar
around right and I got that that's that
Taurus made around stop the leak it
looked like crap though I bet and but
you know what it didn't it wasn't going
to burn the house down because it wasn't
running down the electrical fixture
right and uh it didn't leak it just
really looked awful and Sharon was like
embarrassed it's in the back of the
house no I mean only the neighbors
behind saw it it's not that not the
people on the street saw it but uh
anyway it only lasted like um
you know it was only like a year and a
half before we paid before we paid cash
and put a roof on it but we had to get
the other stuff you know we had to just
stop the leak temporarily until we could
go and get the cash together and get the
debts paid off you got a channel your
inner MacGyver that's it that's what we
did and
um you know
um
it's hard though folks because folks are
watching HGTV I know and they're
watching all of these shows and
everybody can just listen when you're
broken chip and Joanna can't help okay
when you're broke they're no help at all
they're sweet but they're they're when
you're not broke you can't afford
Magnolia stuff I mean you're broke
you know yeah we were broke we're trying
to feed kids we weren't trying to show
off
and so they're sweet people we like chip
and Joanna can't afford that anymore
that's not for broke people and they
don't think their stuff should broke no
but they've got everybody walking into
their house and looking around going oh
well maybe I need to change these floors
or you know we haven't painted in a
while quartz countertops or feed the
baby let me think here suddenly suddenly
you notice the light fixture in your
bathroom like you've never seen it
before but suddenly you notice it and
you go oh that kind of yeah I think I
need one of those yeah I need a new one
to be happy I'll be happy then
Thomas is with us in Las Vegas Hey
Thomas what's up
hey Dave and James it's so great to be
able to talk to you guys a little bit
nervous but excited to talk to you no
trouble we've never lost a patient how
can we help
a career move uh right now I'm currently
getting paid I'm in a niche type field
called medical physics I make 175 000
and right now I got a job offer for
another job it has a medical physicist
up in Utah but I the downside is that
I'd be getting paid 165
000 but the retirement contribution is
14 which is very unique and uh and three
percent right now is what I'm getting
and so I just kind of had two questions
is how should I evaluate if I should
take that job and then also if I do take
the other job that has a 14 contribution
to retirement did that change my 15 baby
step four answer to that is no you are
putting in 15 regardless of what they're
putting in Period that doesn't change
okay now the question don't take a job
over retirement match
that's a good point just don't okay take
a job because it's the right job because
I want to live in that City the upward
potential is there
but if you're down to where the only
thing that's different is a retirement
match you know that's going to wear off
fast who's the best company to work for
which environment is toxic which
environment's not toxic are these people
known as being great people are they
weird
um you know what's your upside if you're
if you got more upside in Vegas than you
do in Salt Lake or wherever it is in
Utah I that's how you take the job
and where does your family want to live
you know we love it here we hate it here
that matters that matters that's part of
the equation take your job based on that
the retirement's just part of the thing
although that is a great match it is
that's wonderful we don't take a job
based on the match
bad bad uh bad fishing lure this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage Nathan and Ella are with us hey
guys how are you good how are you better
than we deserve how much debt have you
guys paid off
165 000 cool how long did this take you
20 months good for you and your range of
income during that time we range from
115 to 175. excellent what do you all do
for a living I'm a project manager and
I'm an occupational therapist in the
school system phenomenal and where do
you guys live we live in Raleigh North
Carolina ah cool welcome to Nashville
good so uh what kind of debt was the
165. every dime of it was my student
once whoa oh did you said occupational
therapist yeah
very cool okay so uh Nathan that's what
you signed up for it is
how long you guys been married about two
years how long you've been out of school
I graduate world ended in May of 2010.
great timing Ella right fantastic
just in time for the world
just in time so what happened 20 months
you know 20 months ago they graduate you
get married and pandemic hits all at the
same time
and you've got this huge student loan
debt well tell us this story
well uh you know before we got married
when we were engaged we
um I was decided to start saving up
money uh knowing that this was coming
and part of our pre-marriage counseling
we
um we did Financial Peace University and
yay Pastor way to go Pastor that was
self-imposed it was not required we
decided to do it well way to go you two
Yeah we actually did it during the uh
the free trials that y'all were offering
at that time so yeah when the world
ended we gave everybody free FPU yeah I
remember yeah
yeah and then once we got married we hit
the ground running hit uh send on all of
uh the money that I had saved up during
that time and that she had uh also paid
off during that time too so how much
money had you saved about fifty thousand
dollars wow you get married and go all
right
I made her push the button
I couldn't do it
man that's true love right there that's
true love I've love it it's well done
it's the way you should do it and we're
joking around but it still kind of gives
you a gulp yeah moment both of you
really because you're going he just took
his 50k and put on my yeah and now we
really are one yeah we really are
married yeah that's true that's real
that's real that's good very good you
guys a lot of maturity shown there
excellent okay so we take 165 we drop 50
on it we're down to 115. we're making
115. now you get your new gig as an
occupational therapist that kicks in
come up and we go game on yep just like
that well and we did lots of side
hustles you know grocery delivery I did
babysitting I got a PRN job at a Skilled
Nursing Facility so we did just about
everything that we could yeah or even
social media Tick Tock that stuff too
wait what do you mean by that uh so we
actually have a dog that's uh famous on
Tick Tock right now so oh oh my gosh
what do you think about that is yeah
George follows her well I need to know
more that's her her name is maple yeah
like bigger Circle what kind of dog is
that it's a Vizsla oh they're great dogs
fantastic I've got a friend that has
three of them they are fabulous so she's
famous on Tick Tock yeah she does all
kinds of funny stuff I bet yeah she pays
her own bills and then some and then
some yeah very cool very cool I need to
get a dog as famous on Tick Tock I know
right get something out of these animals
so and way to go way to go all right
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt-ish well for me uh
it's been learning to say no so you can
say yes later
for me it would be making a budget and
sticking to it first time you did that
huh yes
yeah well I mean
Nathan you had been saying no because
you have money saved yes
so but it was a different kind of no
this time because you're doing it
together with somebody it knits you
together in your first few years of
marriage like nothing else does to
attack this stuff it does it definitely
gives you a purpose yeah and that's so
good I'm just curious so you had the 50
000 saved how did that make you feel
Ella when he was like I'm right in the
chat or you you push the button but how
did that make you feel when you were
like hey this is our money he believes
that I believe that no shame no guilt
we're in this together like how did that
make you feel it made me feel very loved
but then I also felt very guilty every
single budget meeting we had I cried
because I just carried so much shame and
guilt that it was my fault that we were
doing this that we had to go through it
how did you get like how did you
overcome that
step one for me is always tears and then
I feel like we just talked about it a
lot and never once did he like hold it
over my head or blame me or anything it
was always it's okay it sucks right now
but I mean we're gonna be done and then
we get to move on and do the next big
thing and now you are
yeah so proud of y'all well done thank
you you're a neat couple very cool who
uh other than the two of you who was
cheering you on
well I would say our family probably
thought we were pretty crazy but they
were very supportive of our goal yeah
you're a little weird but we love you
anyway yeah yeah they're putting your
dog on Tick Tock
all right very cool well congratulations
you guys we're proud of you excellent
job Heroes excellent job you two are
heroes for sure we've got the live and
give bundle for you to celebrate the
baby steps Millionaire's number one
best-selling book and uh of course
that's the next step for you you're on
your way to doing that you knock out 165
you can have a million it's doable it's
very very doable you got great careers
you know how to work together and you've
set yourself up to attack anything if
you can slay this Dragon together you
can slay any other kind of dragon that
comes at you uh The Total Money Makeover
book as well you'll be able to give that
to somebody and that's inspired by your
story that'll get started a Financial
Peace University membership and either
use it or give that as well it's all the
live and give bundle so you get to do
all all of it or give all of it or
however you want to do it so very very
very well done Nathan and Ella Raleigh
North Carolina 165
000 paid off in 20 months first order of
business after graduation and marriage
very well done 115 to 175 000 income
during that time count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
[Applause]
oh
this is how it's done
Jade
people listening to that can go past and
even that young couple rather Nathan
Nelly can go past real quickly you and
Sam and Sharon and I can't go past real
quickly that the number one cause of
divorce in North America today is money
fights and money problems yes they're
not going to have those nope nope
they're not gonna have those
and what stood out to me very much about
that is he had
for the lack of this conference he had
his money before they were married that
he had saved and he was willing to say
this is ours and he like she said he
didn't make us feel bad about it no
guilt no guilt no guilt tripping no
guilt tripping and I mean she had to
work through that but he's there all
along going no this is ours we're
together I signed up for when you do
that that's um that that's you know the
when you learn to be generous together
to invest together to spend wisely
together when you control all of that
Jesus said your treasure is where your
heart is when you are in agreement about
where the money is going you are in
agreement about your life yeah and they
did that as a first order of business in
their marriage
highly unusual it also sets them up to
win there are couples that have been
married 35 years that don't even know
what the other one has no well it's um
it's maturity and it's letting go of
your ego your ego and your need to be
Power Trip and control that is what says
no this is mine I'm going to keep this
over here everything else we'll do
together but I'm going to keep this
separate to the side it makes no sense
um
you're exactly right if you do that
nothing's getting in between you
dear boys and girls y'all can take a
lesson from them regardless of your age
or uh how long you've been married
that's how you do it right the
probability from the data we have that
that couple is going to be very wealthy
is very high this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
our scripture of the day Acts 20 and 24
however I consider my wife my life worth
nothing to me my only aim is to finish
the race and complete the task of the
Lord Jesus has given me the task of
testifying to the good news of God's
grace Quincy Jones said every day my
daddy told me the same thing once a task
is
Just Begun never leave it until it's
done
be the labor great or small do it well
or not at all oh I like that very cool
our question of the day comes from our
sponsor neighborly now they are uh
pretty incredible they're your hub for
Home Services take your home's
efficiency and style to the next level
with convenient solutions from shelf
Genie window Genie and glass doctor
visit neighborly.com to schedule home
service professionals near you all right
today's question of the day comes from
Damian in Georgia he says I'm 45 years
old and have two thousand dollars of
debt thinking about using a debt relief
program to help get rid of that debt is
that a mistake
now uh
let's let's talk about this two thousand
dollars of debt I don't really know why
you would need any type of consolidation
for that unless maybe you there's a typo
and you meant twenty thousand or two
hundred thousand no matter how much debt
um I would never go the consolidation
route
um and for several reasons number one
you know when people seek out
consolidation I think they're just kind
of trying to hit that easy button and
find an easy way out and they end up you
know Shifting the debt around as opposed
to actually paying it off and it's one
of those things that with those
consolidation companies they're calling
up the credit card companies or they're
they're making deals that you can
actually call in and do yourself you
know I remember when Sam and I were in
dead I'd call up the credit card
companies and I try to get breaks on the
interest and they do it or I try to move
the payment date you know the 18th
doesn't work for me can we move it to
the third all those things that they're
doing for you you can do that yourself
and you don't need to pay somebody to do
it the other thing with those
consolidation companies are of course
they're taking all those debts maybe
you've got 12 different ones and they're
grouping it into one debt and you're
thinking hey I'm going to get a better
interest rate on this but that's not
always the case because they're using
your interest rate it's Consolidated at
your interest rate based on your credit
and chances are if you're to the point
that you need a consolidation company or
you think you do your credit's probably
tanked and so that interest rate is
probably going to be worse off than what
you were before all right Diamond your
debt relief program is called get a job
yeah you got two thousand dollars a debt
two thousand dollars okay dude seriously
go mow some grass I gotta believe this
is a typo two thousand dollars no it's
not it's not
it's but you're exactly right the
problem is that we're trying to look for
a way to make this easy
and the way you pay off two thousand
dollars is you go get two thousand
dollars
that's how you do it if my guy is 45
years old and is honestly thinking yeah
debt consolidation for two thousand
dollars he is he is Damon income go get
some oh that's a scary stuff Joy's in
Minneapolis hi Joy welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave indade how are you great how can
we help
well I we're technically house poor with
my irregular income and we're so tired
of being in debt irregular income
doesn't make you house core poor low
income makes your house poor
okay so my job has super irregular hours
in the winter
um so my husband with just his income
were tightness you don't have enough
income
for our house do you work or not
I do walk out without your income
well but just that it's really irregular
well I mean how much do you make in a
month
um last year I brought in 24 000 in the
year okay how much do you make in a
month
around two
um around two yeah yeah okay that's not
what's causing your problem it's the
fact that you're not making money
56 000 last year okay
and so
you have a um 80 000 household income
what's your house payment
uh 1806-71 good Lord
yeah I know uh we moved right when the
whole house thing yeah let's go
yeah but you bought a house you can't
afford
yeah there's a yes
a joy I'm hearing a lot of excuses every
time Dave says something you're going
yeah but well but and we had to do this
and we had it I I think you got to get
it straight in your head what's really
gone on which is you've got the
irregular income you had the irregular
income before you bought the house and
you guys chose to buy a house and spend
too much for it I feel like you got to
get that straight in your head because
if you don't get those facts straight in
your head you're we're not going to be
able to solve any problems for you today
so one of two things is going to happen
your else income is going to go up
dramatically in the next 24 months or
you're going to have to sell this house
you bought a house you can't afford
okay
that's the numbers I'm sorry
um but that you it's killing you that's
why you called wasn't it
I just I don't know I'm tired of being
in that we're on step three I understand
but the reason is the reason you're
crying is you're starving to death
so if your irregular income was twenty
four thousand dollars in one month
and nothing the rest of the year and you
use the 24 that's the most extreme
irregular income I can think of right
that's a lot of irregular
um and you can just spread out the 24
000 throughout the year and you put it
with his 56. it doesn't pay this house
payment does it
well I crunched the numbers and if we
took if we could win gazelle intense for
six years six years you can't hold off a
40 a payment that's 40 of your income
you can't do that for six years nope
it's gonna blow up somewhere yeah
something's gonna happen and there's
going to be debt starting to pop up
other places because you can't pay your
bills you can't eat it's killing you
it's killing you
is there a way that your 24K can
increase or become or his yeah can we
see can we see either one of your
incomes coming up dramatically
um not his he's already working 50 60
hours a week and he changed careers
could he do something with his career
that goes up
um
not Percy I mean I could work more days
a week
but when we did that last year our
marriage almost ended so yeah it's not
worth it it's just a house it's a stupid
house on every corner
I'm not putting my kids or my marriage
on the block of a stupid house
so y'all sit down look at this tonight
okay and just write it all out and look
at it and go okay I think this thing is
taking more of our joy than it's adding
okay because I think that's what the
math is telling me I think it's stealing
your uh you're you're tired you're
stressed everything's got there's no
margin everything's is everything's
metal on metal it Sparks
you know there's no there's no there's
nothing smooth anymore it's all rough
does that sound right
um
I mean I I saw the light up in this
tunnel when we finished step two like
six years yeah so your take-home pay on
80s about 5k and your payment's almost
2K
yeah
did I miss something our taxable income
our taxable income last year was 80 yeah
yeah I know 80 that's your take-home pay
beware around five
that's something about right a month
yeah you guys got to sit down look at
what you've got coming in because that's
where all this is coming from
so I I you can try whatever you want to
try you're grown-ups but you called us
and we're gonna tell you I I wouldn't
live with a house payment at 40 of my
take-home pay
for for six years because that's a
ticking Time Bomb when the transmission
goes on the car you got no margin when
you need a new car and you've got to
save up and pay cash for it you don't
have the margin to do it when the kid's
sick you don't have the margin to cover
it there's no margin it's metal on metal
everything's friction everything Sparks
and um it's just too short and you know
I'm gonna work overtime for a house only
that I can because I bought something I
can't afford I wouldn't yeah I wouldn't
Jade good hour thanks for a good show
rather thanks for being with me good
stuff that puts this hour of the Ramsey
showing the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
thank you
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]